who are these attackers
from the individual level to the group
level
psychologically speaking what's their
motivation is it purely money
is it the challenge
are they malevolent is it power
these are big philosophical human
questions i guess
so these are the questions i set out to
answer for my book
i wanted to know
are these people that are just after
money
you know if they're just after money how
do they sleep at night not knowing
whether that zero tax plate they just
sold to a broker is being used to
basically make someone's life a living
hell
and what i found was there's kind of
this long sordid history to this
question
you know it started out
in the 80s and 90s when hackers
were just finding holes and bugs and
software for curiosity's sake really as
a hobby
and some of them would go to the tech
companies like microsoft or sun
microsystems at the time
or oracle
and they'd say hey i just found this
zero day in your software and i can use
it to break into nasa
and the general response at the time
wasn't thank you so much for pointing
out this flaw and our software will get
it fixed as soon as possible
it was
don't ever poke around our software ever
again or we'll stick our general counsel
on you
and
that was really sort of the common
thread for years
and so hackers who set out to do the
right thing we're basically told to
shut up and stop doing what you're doing
and what happened next was
they basically started trading this
information online now when you go back
and interview people from those early
days
they all tell a very similar story which
is
they're curious they're tinkerers you
know they remind me of like the kid down
the block that was constantly poking
around the hood of his dad's car
you know they just couldn't help
themselves they wanted to figure out how
a system is designed
and how they could potentially exploit
it for some other purpose it doesn't
have to be good or bad
but they were basically kind of beat
down
for so long
by these big tech companies
that they started just
silently trading them with other hackers
and that's how you got these um
really heated debates in the 90s about
disclosure
should you just dump these things online
because any script kitty can pick them
up and use it for all kinds of mischief
but you know don't you want to just
stick a middle finger to all these
companies that are basically threatening
you all the time
so there was this really interesting
dynamic at play
and
what i learned in the course of doing my
book was that government agencies and
their contractors sort of tapped into
that frustration and that resentment
and they started quietly reaching out to
hackers on these forums
and they said hey you know that zero day
you just dropped online could you could
you come up with something custom for me
and i'll pay you six figures for it so
long as you shut up and never tell
anyone that we that i paid you for this
and that's what happened
so throughout the 90s there was a bunch
of boutique contractors that started
reaching out to hackers on these forums
and saying hey i'll pay you six figures
for that bug you were trying to get
microsoft to fix for free
and sort of so began or so catalyzed
this market
where governments and their
intermediaries started reaching out to
these hackers and buying their bugs for
free
and in those early days i think a lot of
it was just for quiet counter
intelligence traditional espionage
but as we started baking
the software
windows software schneider electric
siemens industrial software into our
nuclear plants
and our factories and our power grid and
our petrochemical facilities and our
pipelines
those same zero days came to be just as
valuable for sabotage and war planning
does the fact that the market sprung up
and you cannot make a lot of money
change the nature of the attackers that
came to the table
or grow the number of attackers
i mean what is i guess you told the
psychology of the hackers
uh in the 90s what is the culture today
and where is it heading so i think there
are people who will tell you they would
never sell a zero day to a zero day
broker or a government
one because they don't know how it's
going to get used when they throw it
over the fence you know most of these
get rolled into classified programs and
you don't know how they get used
if you sell it to a zero day broker you
don't even know which nation state might
use it
or potentially which criminal group
might use it if you sell it on the dark
web
the other thing that they say is
that
they want to be able to sleep at night
and they lose they'd lose a lot of sleep
if they found out their zero day was
being used to you know make a
dissident's life living hell
um but there are a lot of people good
people who also say
no this is not my problem this is the
technology company's problem if they
weren't writing new bugs into their
software every day
then there wouldn't be a market you know
then there wouldn't be a problem
but they continue to write bugs into
their software all the time and they
continue to profit off that software so
why shouldn't i
profit off my
labor too
and one of the things that has happened
which is i think a positive development
over the last 10 years
are bug bounty programs
you know companies like google and
facebook and then microsoft and finally
apple which resisted it for a really
long time
have said okay
we are going to shift our perspective
about hackers we're no longer going to
treat them as the enemy here
we're going to start paying them for
what it's essentially free quality
assurance
and we're going to pay them good money
in some cases you know six figures in
some cases
we're never going to be able to bid
against a zero-day broker who sells to
government agencies
but we can reward them and hopefully get
that to that bug earlier where we can
neutralize it
so that they don't have to spend another
year developing the zero day exploit and
in that way we can keep our software
more secure
but every week i get messages from some
hacker that says
you know i tried to see this zero day
exploit that was just found in the wild
you know being used by this nation state
i tried to tell microsoft about this
two years ago and they were going to pay
me peanuts so
it never got fixed you know there are
all sorts of those stories that can
continue on
and
you know i think just generally
hackers are not very good at diplomacy
you know they tend to be pretty snipey
technical
crowd
and very philosophical in my experience
but you know diplomacy is not their
strong suit
well there almost has to be a broker
between companies and hackers
where you can translate effectively just
like you have a zero-day broker between
governments and hackers yeah because you
have to speak their language yeah and
there have been some of those companies
who've risen up to meet that demand and
hacker one is one of them bug crowd is
another synac has an interesting model
so that's a company that
you pay for a private bug bounty program
essentially so you pay this company they
tap hackers
all over the world
to come hack your software hack your
system
and then they'll quietly tell you what
they found
um and i think that's a really positive
development and actually the department
of defense hired all three of those uh
companies i just mentioned to help
secure their systems now i think they're
still a little timid in terms of letting
those hackers into the really sensitive
high side classified stuff
but you know baby steps
just to understand what you were saying
you think it's im impossible for
companies to financially compete with
the zero day brokers with governments
so like the defense can't outpay
the um the hackers it's interesting you
know they
they shouldn't out pay them because what
would happen if they started offering
2.5 million dollars at apple
for any you know zero day exploit that
governments would pay that much for
is their own engineers would say why the
hell am i working you know for less than
that
and and doing my nine to five every day
so you would create a perverse incentive
and i didn't i didn't think about that
until i started this research and i
realized okay yeah that makes sense you
don't want to
incentivize offense so much that it's to
your own detriment
and so i think what they have though
what the companies have on government
agencies
is
if they pay you you get to talk about it
you know you get the street cred you get
to brag about the fact you just found
that 2.5 million dollar
you know ios zero day that no one else
did
and if you sell it to a broker you never
get to talk about it and i think that
really does eat at people
you